well i there's good news there is a
political party that's going to find us
a way out
i love you so much i love doing this
show i love this show
let's make history michael what's going
on with the libertarian party in new
hampshire
lydia has the documents yes okay so
this is i i am going to give a garbled
version of this because this is like
playing telephone but i'm very very glad
i get to do this because then everyone
could be like okay he's talking out of
his butt
let me double check and when they look
it up they'll be like no this is right
so dave smith who's this aspiring
comedian you guys have had on the show
he's great
amazing he is a big member of the
libertarian party and his followers are
something called the mises caucus which
is named after this very failed think
tank the music institute
so they are the more radical of the
libertarians right
so he's brought a lot of energy to the
libertarian party which has historically
and correctly been regarded as a joke
and state by state they've had these
conventions and they've been electing
their slates for delegates whatever the
position is
and the meecox people have been running
the table because he's just bringing all
the energy
and it's all these kind of like lowest
status uh people who have nothing to
bring to the table of then
this is their chance to be members of
the party they won in new hampshire
new hampshire of all the states this is
i completely uh
could be wrong in this one that's the
home of free state project that's where
all the hardcore libertarians move to
and people can look at the free state
projects a great idea
i highly encourage people look it up
what happened was what was the woman's
name which is
gigi i sent you the the the woman who's
the head of the libertarian party of new
hampshire
unilaterally saying hello to jarvis
jilletta jarvis she was the
she was their candidate for governor she
she's
i sent the letter please you can read it
where she basically said
everyone who was in the libertarian
party previously
is now not part of the libertarian party
i
am the libertarian party because i got
unanimously voted to be the chair
i'm going to pass a new series of bylaws
unilaterally no one vote on them
i am going to extend my term to four
years no one vote on this
and now this is the new lp and you guys
are not the lp
right wow so they are like well we have
all the bank accounts
and all the everything else she has
their twitter their twitter
i just know that i went
she has their twitter and their social
media and this was a huge drama it's
like you just stole
the entire thing and you're worried
about this kind of like alt-right thing
you're acting like a fuhrer
the libertarian national committee had a
meeting
on youtube you could go look it up a
couple days ago they voted
and they basically endorsed what she did
they're like how they're like look if
you want to like uh dissolve
one state party we have that in our like
constitution or bylaws which is
you have a meeting you call a motion
you're like all right three quarters of
vote i think it is this libertarian part
of new hampshire dissolves a nuclear
option we're going to reform it
she's like we didn't do that if you want
to do that let's have the vote they're
like nope
now the guy who's the head of the
libertarian party john bishop henchmen i
think is his name he sent out a letter
which lydia has and he says anyone by
the way i should let you know as a
lawyer this is great libertarianism
uh anyone who cast aspersions on my
integrity
or can you please read it blah blah blah
blah is setting themselves up for legal
action just so you're warned
and people like whoa wait you're the
head of the libertarian party
very arguably a public figure and you're
threatening lawsuits against fellow
libertarians
but apparently i got a message from dave
that they completely lost everything's
getting handed over right now
yeah i'm seeing a lot of pushback
against the libertarian party on twitter
and the free state project
tweeted a couple days ago quote the free
state project was explicitly
founded as a result of the continued
failures of the libertarian party
we're thrilled to see new hampshire be
growing increasingly libertarian
and very few free staters care what
party does it
uh so a lot of people are pushing back
and i'm seeing people burning t-shirts
i'm seeing some people
sell the t-shirts i am here to declare
let me finish this by point
following suit with what's her name
again jarvis
i am here by declaring that i'm actually
the chairman of the libertarian party
that all these people who are claiming
to be otherwise are uh uh fraudulent i'm
kind of the libertarian party chairman
of exile
and i expect all the party assets to be
returned to me according to the new
bylaws which i'm writing which will be
forthcoming
can i second to that yes absolutely
so look i got a couple questions the
free state project is that like where
they're trying to get all the people to
come there and like become residents and
then vote for freedom or something yes
and slowly go into positions in local
government
and they have elected a large number of
local representatives that passed a lot
of local laws
including ones where you could now
choose your tax dollars to go
to nonprofits that teach people how to
homeschool their children
so your taxes could effectively go
towards efforts that free children and
educate them through a community way
instead of a public schooling way
and new hampshire slowly and surely is
implementing a lot of different actions
a lot of different proposals and they're
getting them through which is absolutely
exciting
how are the taxes in new hampshire
it's one of the lowest tax places but
property taxes are a little bit high but
it's it's the place that has
it's the place that has some of the
highest gun ownership and the least the
highest yeah yeah and then the least
amount of murders yeah at least the
amount of crime
the the the place with the highest iq
the most amount of home school children
uh the place that has the most economic
opportunities and the most amount of
bitcoiners
and more bitcoin transactions than any
other state
because they have a list of all the
things that are awesome i mean this is
why i moved to
new hampshire and i'm going to be going
back there in just a few days to be a
part of
pork festivals
there's actually a lot of polish people
in new hampshire let's go back to this
lady what's the url though
hold on i'll pull it up certainly let's
go to this lady
jarvis she's trying to take over the
party no no she has taken over she's
declared herself to be the party she's
declared it she is the fear of the
libertarian party
uh is it because dave smith they don't
like or yeah because
they're saying dave smith is bringing
all these bigots and racists and all
these other cathedral terms
and that that's not what we're about so
oh my god i finished i forgot the best
part
she said and this is if you go to lp nh
their twitter
the libertarian part of new hampshire if
you want to join the libertarian party
new hampshire
you have to sign or say i don't remember
what their mechanism is a loyalty oath
that she wrote
what and she put go to lpnh their
twitter what
is it just at lpnh yeah i believe so
it's a big graphic interesting let me
see if i can
when did they post it within the last
week maybe the 12th
so michael is this just because they've
gotten woke is that a symptom
they've been woke and now they're being
this is what it is the libertarian party
is a mechanism for lowest status people
to have some modicum of respect and do
something with their lives
and now that they're being outnumbered
and the only thing that's of value to
them is being taken away
of course they're going to use every
trick at their disposal to maintain
their hold on this minuscule amount of
power now this is my interpretation
they of course have a different
perspective that we're keeping
libertarian parties safe from nazis
dave smith even those family or
holocaust survivors but that is kind of
the two sides of this issue yeah and
it's hilarious because
i was watching that youtube of the uh
executive channel meeting
and i go this must have been what the
communist party meetings were like in
the 30s
except everyone's on the spectrum yeah
so so dave smith tweeted the lpnh fiasco
has been resolved the attempted coup has
failed
this was not an lpmc versus lp thing
this was a few corrupt people versus all
of the decent honorable people of the
libertarian in the libertarian party
real spike cohen justin amash uh yeah
carrie what does this carry on harlow
carlos yes
and others displayed true integrity so i
wonder if they took down the loyalty of
things i couldn't find it
oh wow they might i'll look forward to
the other thing is they were threatening
legal action they're like okay
this has nothing to do with your
politics like no one vote on this
you can't just one lady say these the
new bylaws that makes no sense
right so if uh if i vote for um
dave smith will i get a
press secretary michael malus along with
it yeah so here's my
here's what my deal was okay if you go
to malice or press secretary.com
i said to myself the only way i would
sign on
to i would repress sarah during the
campaign not even in presidency
i would say i would sign on as
communications director if i had
one bitcoin a month in the bank as
security
because if they came for me and they try
to completely cancel me and destroy me
and all these smear pieces
i have to know i'm not gonna be homeless
that would be the greatest thing we have
seen in politics in my lifetime
and this i promised people and i will
i and i will say this right now and i'll
affirm to it under oath
i would unleash such a season of poison
on social media that donald trump would
look like mother teresa
i'm not kidding the amount of hatred and
contempt i have for political class
is so off the charts that i literally
can't even talk about it
because the show i would be on would be
cancelled i um
that's not saying much now i mean
everyone gets canceled now
i would like to see a michael mouse
press secretary very much i would too
yeah he would be very entertaining i
want to be part of the part of the
cabinet man let's roll
let's build free software i want it to
happen i feel like you'd be the hunter
biden of this administration
just have me over for
[Music]
psychedelics all the way i'm not into
the the crazy stuff no crack i'm
you know no cocaine have you tried crack
negative okay i've had friends that
tried it
not into stimulants and downers and
uppers i just like psychedelics drugs
are bad okay
hey yeah sugar but what i want to see
is your quick wit when the journalists
come asking questions you know what i
would do i'll tell you exactly tell me
what you do
uh the thing that is a real issue with
washington
is that everyone it's very incestuous
now in a way it's it sounds worse than
it is because if you're all like in like
a
upper middle upper class and you're all
swimming the same circles
of course the person who works for this
organization works is going to marry
someone who works for this university i
mean these are the circles you travel in
but to americans it looks much more
nefarious and i think in a sense it is
more affairs than people realize because
if your wife works for this charity
you're kind of going to be
have a different relationship to it you
can't help it this is your wife this is
her life's work right
but if you have that press secretary
constantly pointing out these
relationships
this is really going to a upset them
which is a good in and of itself
but it'll also point out to americans
just how the system is us versus them
at it's george carlin it's a big club
and you ain't in it
so i think it's the same big club they
used to beat you over the head with yeah
so this is the kind of thing where i
think people will be very receptive
because it's one thing to be aggressive
like oh you're an idiot you're a fake
news
it's not to be like look you guys are
all in this big kind of high school
thing
and that leaves the average guy out in
the streets and president smith is doing
something about it because he's much
more of a schlub
than he is one of you it would be
probably how he dresses it's a disaster
it's a complete embarrassment i don't
say it others do
i think the libertarian party uh for the
longest time
was i don't want to say controlled
opposition
but you look at joe jorgensen coming out
and saying and telling people what they
must do was that was one of the funniest
things about she went to dershow it's a
part of the supreme court
wow yeah that's that's well she said it
is not enough to be
not racist we must be actively
anti-racist and i was like
sure is something seen the libertarian
party telling me what i must do
the libertarian party in new hampshire
unfollowed me
as we're speaking it follows you when i
hit refresh you went away
oh but they took it back it said so one
minute ago literally one minute ago the
pin tweet
three exclamation points the libertarian
part of new hampshire is now in control
of our assets and data
we would like to sincerely thank those
in the lnc who came to our defense and
those who supported us
help us further our mission at and the
link is anarchist handbook.com
so if you want to help the libertarian
party make sure you buy the enemy thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you